hello I'm Nick Larkin Doha the top
stories here on Al Jazeera and a series
of explosions followed by repeated
gunfire have been heard in Kabul and I
went and says the explosion took place
at a building rented by Chinese
investors our Men Storm the building and
opened fire not yet known who's behind
the attack or if there are any
casualties well let's get the very
latest our producer goes in carmeland
joins us on the phone from Kabul so
Mason tell us what more you know
uh hi uh so uh for now we know that the
building was attacked by some uh a few
attackers around 2 30 this evening
initially uh it was that the two Taliban
guards were killed right on the spot uh
at the gate and then the attackers went
inside the building and started fighting
so uh it was like four big blasts in the
uh in the in the start and Then followed
by continuous firing and gunshots and
then there was this huge fire in the
building and uh which uh later there was
a huge blast in the end so uh there
seems to be like two attackers killed
they're cutting the security officials
and um two of the Taliban are killed for
now
um the security forces are in the area
the fire has been uh put off by the
firefighters and the floors have been
cleared until the the the the the fifth
floor so the building is around seventh
floor so it's still neat sometimes and
there are quite a few gunshot HUD or
like after after a while so the building
is still not cleared
um but the fire is still put off that
that's all we know and in the recent
days after the Russia and the Pakistani
Embassy attack this is considered the
third attack on the Chinese and the
building was usually guarded and the
street was often closed by the security
officials in order to secure the
building
all right motion we'll leave it there
thanks very much indeed for that update
admission card my mind uh joining us on
the phone from Kabul on that series of
explosions followed by repeated gunfire